fellas you got to love a spider with a
big ass you know what I'm saying the
opening scene features Los Angeles where
the people are seen running here and
there in panic in order to save their
lives it turns out that a giant spider
has attacked the city and rre Havoc
despite several army helicopters
attempts to subdue the creature they
prove futile the scene then shifts to
the flashback before this incident we
are introduced to the protagonist Alex
matthys who is a cash strapped but
good-natured exterminator working in Los
Angeles as a part of his job Alex is
helping an elderly lady with her rodent
problem after capturing the insects he
is preparing to leave when the woman
follows him to his vehicle that's not
the road in I me sunny as usual she has
no money to pay him but she gives him a
cake expressing her gratitude Alex
graciously accepts it but he seems
somewhat disturbed by the woman's
apparent affection for him their
conversation is suddenly interrupted by
a spider that crawls on Alex's shoulder
which he recognizes as a venomous one he
asks the elderly lady to stay calm as it
won't hurt until it is threatened
however the woman disregards his
instructions and proceeds to swat it
with her slipper as a result the spider
bites him and and he ends up in the
hospital while being treated Alex tries
to flirt with a hospital nurse but she
does not seem to be interested in him
she tends to his wounds whilst
simultaneously rebuffing his rather
cliche advances elsewhere in the
hospital morg a worker is startled by
the movement m in one of the body bags
amidst the flickering lights he
nervously approaches the bag just then
something with long legs appears from
behind and bites him on his neck in a
state of panic the worker sounds the
fire alarm causing an evacuation of the
building shortly after he is brought to
the reception where the irritable
Hospital manager scolds him for making a
false fire alarm however the man is sure
that he was attacked by something much
bigger than a spider Alex who is also
present at the scene volunteers to
handle the situation citing his
expertise with spiders and also horny
broke old ladies but that's not
important right now in exchange for this
he requests the manager to cover his
Hospital expenses the ladder promptly
agrees and Alex is taken to the morg by
a security guard named Jose upon
entering the room Alex discovers the
dead body within which the spider had
been living after a bit of research he
notices an open air vent and deduces
that the spider escaped into it good
thing they called in the Pro he then
decides to enter the vent andh hands
Jose aaki talki to keep in contact in
the meantime a US military task force
led by Major Braxton Tanner and
Lieutenant Carly brand shows up at the
hospital to assess the situation the
hospital manager tries to clarify that
it was a false fire alarm but the major
seems to be aware of the spider outbreak
through their conversation it is clear
that the Army is hunting down the
creature which they refer to as a
contagion elsewhere in a hospital
wardroom a paralyzed patient spots the
same same spider emerging from an air
vent gradually it advances beneath his
blanket heading towards his head the
immobilized man tries to press the alarm
button but the spider soon attacks his
face resulting in his brutal demise back
inside the ventilation system Alex
reaches a junction and contacts Jose for
guidance while navigating he notices
something passing by prompting him to
investigate with extra caution he heads
forward only to stumble upon a spiderweb
he simply tries to sweep it aside but it
turns turn out to be very sticky unlike
the other spiderwebs using his supposed
knowhow he pulls out a lighter to burn
it off but it is so flammable that it
almost catches his hands on fire sticky
and flammable that's not a spiderweb
that's jizz meanwhile major Braxton
receives information about the spider's
victim in the wardro prompting him and a
forensic doctor to investigate upon
examination the doctor figures out that
the man died approximately 10 minutes
earlier he theorizes that the spider is
selecting its prey very smartly he also
what what he also claims that the
creature is growing exponentially and
that it has already quadrupled in size
according to the doctor it will
quadruple again if it continues to hunt
and feed in this manner on the other
hand Alex reaches the hospital basement
there he locates the spider inside a
canned bottle in an attempt to lure it
out he rolls a penny towards it much to
his shock a big spider attacks the penny
and carries it away Alex immediately
sprays the acid towards it but the
spider is so fast that it is already
behind him moments before it can launch
an attack on him Lieutenant Carly
arrives at the stairs and shoots towards
the creature this scares the spider
causing it to escape into the sewer
meanwhile Alex who is unaware about the
gravity of the situation gets angry with
Carly for interrupting his work the
lieutenant then takes him to the major
who asks him about what he witnessed
however all he can say is that it's the
biggest spider he's ever encountered in
his life upon hearing that Al Alex does
not have much information about it major
Braxton asks Lieutenant Carly to escort
him out as the two exit the hospital
Alex repeatedly requests that she allow
him to help the military but she denies
him he also presses for more information
about the spider but Carly doesn't say
anything before parting ways the two of
them exchanged their cards asking to
give a call if needed do you want my
Instagram too no after the lieutenant
leaves Jose convinces Alex to continue
their Pursuit as it could be the most
important thing of their lives later on
a homeless guy is wandering inside the
sewer in hopes of finding something to
eat during this time he notices a penny
embedded into a spider web I love
pennies he proceeds to grab at it but
the spider appears from behind it
splashes acid like liquid on the
beggar's face before killing him he
didn't want acid on his face tonight but
Beggars can't be choosers the scene then
cuts to the military headquarters where
the major lieutenant and Doctor monitor
their forces who are inspecting a sewer
leading to the LA River inside they
discover that the spider has already
entrapped 20 to 30 people in a web
indicating its progression to stage
three Alex and Jose also arrive at the
scene and keep an eye on the military
from a distance Jose then calls
Lieutenant Carly to ask whether the
spider is caught or not upon learning
that it's still free the two try to
guess its next destination Alex says
that the spider will need both a food
source and tree cover hearing this Jose
speculates that it might be at a nearby
public park so the two head there true
to their assumption the spider which is
now grown excessively is in the public
park but on their way they are pulled
over by a cop for speeding in order to
make it to the park in time Alex bribes
the officer and drives away meanwhile
the spider attacks an old man who's
exercising it soon goes on a killing
spree by taking down anyone on its way
which creates chaos not long after Alex
and de Jose arrive at the park and
locate the creature Alex initially
decides to Ram it with his truck but he
changes his mind after when witnessing
its immense size as he drives away the
spider starts pursuing them through the
park in the midst of this Lieutenant
Carly calls Alex warning him that he is
approaching a military Crossfire but
before he can change his Direction the
military opens fire towards the creature
a huge firefight ensues but the spider
escapes into the nearby Woods after this
all the military soldiers including
Lieutenant Carly arm themselves with
additional weapons and prepare to pursue
the creature Alex once again tries to
convince the lieutenant to allow him to
accompany them but she again refuses she
appreciates whatever he did until now
but asks him to stay out of trouble the
soldiers then Venture into the woods
only to be ambushed one after another
amidst of this chaos Lieutenant Carly
gets stuck in an extremely sticky
spiderweb hot but before the creature
turns its attention towards her Alex
shows up and releases her right then
Jose appears armed with a gun and begins
shooting at the spider this diversion
allows them to flee the scene however
they are not able to outrun the creature
and as a result it wraps up the
lieutenant with its web and takes her
away in the next scene Alex and Jose get
back to the military headquarters and
ask the major to rescue Carly but he
responds that it is already too late for
it at the same time the forensic doctor
informs the major that the creature is
going for stage five hearing this Alex
and Jose demand answers as to what's
going on major Braxton finally reveals
that they had discovered alien DNA and
hoped to use it as a growth hormone
however a spider's Nest was hidden in
some test fruit thus exposing the spider
to the alien DNA and triggering its
rapid growth freaking freaking test
fruit Man based on their studies of the
alien DNA the doctor claims that the
spider will soon start reproducing
shortly after they learn that the now
enormous spider is heading towards
downtown LA CCTV cameras capture its
Rampage through streets and Towers
creating Havoc it soon creates a nest on
top of the US Bank Tower in a desperate
attempt to take down the giant Beast the
major grants the order for an air strike
he must have gotten a three kill spree
Alex reminds that thousands of people's
lives are on the line but the major
claims that he has to take this step to
save millions of others as the
helicopters approach the bank Tower they
noticed that the lieutenant is still
alive and that she is bundled up in webs
alongside the spider's eggs seeing this
the major who now believes in Alex and
Jose allows them to rush to Carly's
rescue following this Alex and his
associate grab an array of weapons and
set out on their mission they're
battling Against Time with the air
strike a matter of minutes away and the
spider's eggs already beginning to hatch
on their way Alex deduces that shooting
its spinnerette can kill this big ass
spider upon their arrival at the bank
Tower the duo takes an elevator to get
to the top once there they start freeing
Carly as well as the other trapped
victims a few moments later a number of
spider Offspring emerge from their eggs
and launch an attack attack on them they
shoot down some of them and manage to
make it back to the elevator shortly
after their departure the air strike
hits the mother spider knocking it off
the tower believing that the threat has
ended the major calls Alex and commence
his Brave work however it turns out that
the danger is not yet resolved as the
spider gets back up determined to bring
an end to the Menace Alex grabs a rocket
launcher and fires it at the spider's
spinnerette finally finishing it off in
the aftermath of the event Alex and
Carly share a passion Embrace and kiss
in the middle of the road marking the
beginning of their new relationship
seeing this Jose jokingly asks them to
get a room God damn it Jose could you
not have come up with something a little
better than that in a mid-credit scene
major Braxton calls Alex to convey
another impending issue in the
background of the call a video monitor
reveals a giant cockroach climbing the
Statue of Liberty subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching